hello
my name is jonik mahaus and today i will
present our paper batched vertex cover
reconfiguration
this is joint work with karen setzer
hiller shafa roman pellet and t grant
tomigan were all from the turkmen
so
as said this paper is about vertex cover
reconfiguration so how to get from one
vertex cover to another vertex camera
so let's start
so let's start with some motivation and
some gentle introduction into the topic
so consider computer network
and what you want to do here for
security reasons you want to monitor all
links
so you place some agents some of the
vertices some of the computers such that
every adjacent link
is monitored
but now after some time
maintenance is needed so what you will
want to do is you will change the
monitoring machines here
and select different ones
and
what you of course want to do is even
during the change
you want to always monitor all of the
edges
and what we want to do here is we want
to
study the smooth transition
from
one set of monitoring machines to
another one
and formally the set of monitoring
machines is nothing but a vertex cover
so subset of the vertices
that touch
all of the edges
so
the problem that we've just seen is
formerly known as the vertex cover
reconfiguration problem
so here you're given an initial vertex
coverage you denote it as alpha the blue
vertices
and the final vertex cover here denoted
as beta the green vertices
then the goal is to compute the
reconfiguration scheduler
that is a sequence of vertex covers
where the first vertex cover is alpha
and the last vertex cover is better
and two consecutive vertex covers are
only allowed to be
changed to differ by a single vertex so
in this example here we could for
example first add this green vertex here
to the vertex cover then we can remove
two of these
two vertices up here from the cover
because
these edges are covered by the green
vertex
and now we can add another of the green
vertices
remove more and so on until we've
reached the vertex cover better
the length of such a
reconfiguration schedule is one of the
parameters of interest
but throughout this talk we will only
consider so-called monotone schedules
where you can only change
each vertex once so it can only just
leave the vertex color once or
join the vertex color once and if you
then look at sequential vertex color
reconfiguration
the length is always just the symmetric
difference of the initial and the final
vertex cover
and the cost as usual with vertex
however you want to
get vertex covers a small size is the
maximum
intermediate vertex cover so what you
want to do to achieve here normally is
that your intermediate vertex covers
throughout the reconfiguration
process are also small
and then one thing that has been
classically studied is the vertex cover
reconfiguration decision problem so
you're given a graph
and some parameter k as well as two
vertex covers alpha and beta so that
given as part of the input
is their schedule with cost at most k
and it's known that this is a difficult
problem it's piece based complete and
even
on planar graphs with degree at most
three
and even bipartite graphs but there are
examples where the problem is actually
in p
on for example so-called even hopeful
graphs
so in this paper
we want to provide a new angle to this
vertex calibrate configuration
problem and recon refigure faster
because if you're in such a large
network then you can maybe
add two vertices to the vertex cover at
the same time if they're not in conflict
or also remove some or
at the same time if there's no conflict
in these actions
so what we will look at in this paper is
batch
reconfiguration where you're allowed to
change more than one vertex at a time
so let's see how do we need to change
the definition of a reconfiguration
schedule
before what we had this year that we are
only allowed to change one vertex at a
time now we change this that we allow to
change an unbounded number of vertices
what can happen if you just try to do
this well one bad idea is
to just in one change just
without any further restrictions you can
just immediately go from the initial
vertex cover alpha to better just in one
batch and you're there and you're done
why is this nothing that we want to do
well
if we execute all these changes
in one batch well in this batch we have
some
agents which leave the vertex cover some
nodes which leave the vertex cover
others which join the vertex cover
and they're all in the same batch but if
you look at the system where you want to
monitor some links you know see that
it's actually
an asynchronous implementation of these
changes and we cannot assume that all of
them happen exactly at the same time
even so they are
in some batch
so what we assume here is that we don't
have a control on the order inside
a batch we don't know in which
order these
changes to the current vertex cover will
be executed
but still what we want to have is
feasibility a validity so we still want
at each point
every edge is monitored by at least one
of its endpoints and it's clear that
here
if
we put both endpoints here
into one batch adding this green vertex
and removing this blue one here then it
might be that the removal of the blue
vertex is executed first
and then this edge is not monitored
anymore
so we need further restrictions to
prevent this so we
really do have
a monitoring
of all edges at the right time
so one can easily circumvent that by
okay one can say i just start with my
initial vertex cover
then i add
all the vertices
which
are in the green vertex cover
and then i remove the ones from the blue
vertex cover so i just have two steps
here i have a lot of parallelism it's
very fast
but the problem here really is okay in
this previous step in this intermediate
step here
we actually have a vertex curve which is
very large which is almost all of the
vertices
and this is also
nothing that we want
it's too expensive we want small
intermediate solutions
and we also want these small immediate
intermediate solutions regardless of
which order inside a match
the changes are actually applied
so what's our definition
of a batched
reconfiguration schedule to obtain both
of these changes and to have both of
these
so
a batch reconfiguration schedule and now
it's actually complete not incomplete
it's a reconfiguration schedule
where after each batch
we have to output a vertex cover
we can change as many
vertices
at a time as we want not just one
but
we need
that even in an adversarial sequential
execution
order within a batch each edge is
covered at all times
this can for example
be
achieved if one always just reconfigures
in one batch nodes which form an
independent set
this is an equivalent statement
and for the cost
we simply
charge
the schedule
for the cost that can be happen and
appear in a worst case
order
of
applying the changes within a batch
so if you look at
the change from ci to ci plus one some
changes in from one batch it might be
that the order is such that first all
additions
are done and only afterwards the
removals so
it might be that the worst case
bound on the size is actually achieved
which just is
the union of two consecutive vertex
covers
so this is the definition of a batch
reconfiguration schedule
and this is the object that we mostly
study in this paper
so
since this is
something which has not been studied
before we have quite
a large number of results here and we
have some centralized results
which are on the existential
side we show that certain schedules
exist
also some polynomial time algorithms and
we have
distributed results where we
present the stimulated algorithms to
compute such schedules
i won't be able to present all our
results in this slide but let me give
you a short overview of what kind of
results we have
so let's first
start with what we've seen we've seen
that we introduced this new concept of
batched schedules
and then we also have
a generic method to create such edge
schedules if you have sequential
schedules
we will look at this in detail later but
the bottom line here is if you have
order of one over epsilon batch
schedules
then you just use a one plus epsilon
factor
in the optimal cost
and this is actually
optimal
then we have several new sequential
schedules for various graph classes such
as planar graphs bound diversity graphs
and also we unify some proofs for
already
known sequential schedules for different
graph classes
and we provide some existential lower
balance
and we also provide
some
very short
schedules for planar and bounded
diversity brass which really just have
four badges
this is
a quick overview of centralized results
then we also have distributed results
where we have distributed algorithms
later tell you what these are
to compute such batch schedules
so
we complement these results with lower
bounds weighted
and unweighted lower bounds
and
we also present distributed algorithms
using different techniques to get
schedules with different
trade-offs
so since these are
quite a large number of results
i will only focus on
two of these results which are easiest
to present here
in this short talk so we'll first start
with this scheduled compression here
which takes a sequential
reconfiguration schedule
and a certain length and compresses it
basically what it does it
creates a new schedule which just has a
small number
of batches without increasing the cost
a lot so
sequential to batch
and now let me first start with what do
i mean
i only some
one plus epsilon factor increase in the
cost this is more or less
what you know from classic approximation
algorithms we say a schedule
is an ether c approximation
if it's cost
is at most eta times m plus c
where m
is
this is different from how
approximations are usually defined it's
not the optimal the cost of an optimal
schedule
because we don't know what it is and
sometimes it's even be complete to
compute but
actually
m is just a lower bound
on the optimal schedule
set this m
to the maximum of the initial and the
final vertex because any schedule has to
start with alpha and with better
so the cost of any schedule will always
be at least this maximum
and you can define these approximation
cost for sequential schedules and for
edge schedules
and our theorem says that if you have
monotone sequential schedule which
achieves an approximation
then we can create a monotone batch
schedule
with just one over epsilon matches order
of one of
silent batches and we only use one in
the additive factor here
and an
epsilon in the multiplicative factor of
the approximation
let's go
for the core ideas of this proof
so what we're given here is a sequential
reconfiguration schedule
now we enumerate the elements in the
schedule so all the elements of beta
that we add we enumerate them as v1 v2
b3 before
the order how they appear in the
schedule and we do the same for the
elements of alpha that we remove
from the vertex cover in the order how
they appear
in the schedule note that the numbers
are just within
beta
and within alpha
this is different
for the next definition which is a time
or the slot
in the schedule
which a node appears
so for example the time
when a1 appears in the schedule is 4
because of the force element in the
schedule by the time of b4 is six it's a
sixth element in the schedule
and with this
definitions we can come to one
observation
the observation is
that the time of
bi plus c
is larger than the time
of
a i
sounds pretty technical but what does
this mean we are here in this situation
up here we basically show well there
might be some vertices in between here
but we show that ai comes in the stream
or not in the stream in the schedule
before b i plus c
and this basically just means that if
we've added
v1
until the i plus c
we can safely remove
a1 to ai
without getting any problems with
uncovered and not monitored edges
because the same happens
in the original schedule this is all
what this means
so let's look at a proof of the
statement
this is
just by contradiction
this was not 3.
then after adding v1
until bi plus c
we only would have removed a1
to ai minus
1. so that would mean at this point in
time here after we've added
this vertex here the size of the vertex
cover will just be the initial vertex
cover plus the number of vertices that
we've added
minus i minus 1 and this is a
contradiction
to the approximation guarantee that the
schedule provides us
so with this observation
we can now compress the schedule simply
as follows
we set the parameter k
which determines how many batches we
will get in the end
and then we give
the vertices in beta that we want to add
a head start of
c vertices
and afterwards we always just add k
vertices of beta
remove k vertices of alpha
at the next k vertices in the original
schedule from beta and remove the next k
vertices
from alpha
and this observation shows that in this
case never get a problem with
validity
all edges are always covered at all
times so this is the schedule
that we then get in the end
to summarize the schedule
you have this compressed schedule here
yeah always have all edges covered even
if these batches
are executed
in
any sequential adversarial
order
where i mean within the batch it's
executed in an adversary order the
schedule lengths well each of these
batches here has size at least k
so we will just have
the number the original schedule divided
by k as the lengths
and the cost well the maximum cost is
achieved here at this point in time
after we give this head start and we add
another k vertices
that's where we have the maximum cost
because afterwards we always just remove
k vertices add k vertices remove k
vertices
add k vertices and so on so here's where
we have the maximum cost and what is the
cost here at the initial vertex cover
plus c plus k vertices this is how many
we added and just do the math and you
end up
with the claimed approximation vector
and this is several implications
for the existence of batch schedules
example for cactus graphs practice
graphs are graphs where each edge is in
at most one cycle
and one knows from previous work that
these always have one comma two
approximation schedules
and no one can just use the compression
seam to see that
cactus graphs have
reconfiguration schedules order of one
over epsilon batches
and an approximation vector of one plus
epsilon comma three
and actually these proofs don't need
that the whole graph g instead of this
graph but only that the symmetric
difference of these two vertex covers is
the character's graphs
and this is why this results actually
hold for larger classes of graphs
and
we have more such existential results
also for planar graphs and bounded
diversity graphs so look into the paper
for the additional results
that i don't want to mention now
instead now i want to talk a bit about
our actual motivation why we even the
reason why we looked at this problem and
this comes from the student computing
because in the distributed setting this
is where it really makes sense
that you don't reconfigure nodes one by
one sequentially
consider some very large
network there
where communication
from one end of the network to the other
end of the network takes a very long
time it doesn't make sense
that
these notes coordinate and wait for each
other we want to actually achieve a lot
of parallelism and even deal with parts
of the graphs
more or less independently
so let's
look at the model that we consider here
in the distributed setting this is a
classic message basic model
the so-called local model where we take
such a communication network we could
just see it here communication network
and we abstract it as a graph
everyone has a unique id
and now these
nodes in the graph they can communicate
with each other and this communication
happens in discrete synchronous rounds
so in one round vertex can perform some
local computations
and exchange messages with all of its
neighbors
and everyone here acts at the same time
and we do not charge
the vertices for the local computations
and also the message size is unbounded
so the term complexity is only the
number of synchronous
rounds
until
we've solved the problem at hand so
one thing to point out here is that all
nodes act simultaneously here and all
nodes start in the same round zero so
this model abstracts away a lot of
things but it's one of the classic
models in that area so what does this
model now mean for
the vertex cover reconfiguration problem
so
the setting that we have in the vertex
star reconfiguration problem is that one
of these networks in the graph here one
of these nodes computers the graph
doesn't know what the graph looks like
all that they know at the start of the
computation is their own id
and they know whether they are in the
initial vertex cover alpha
and whether they are in the vertex cover
better that's their knowledge then they
can talk to other vertices learn a bit
more about the network learn the status
and alpha
and better of the other nodes at some
point they've seen information from some
part of the network some part they
haven't seen
and still
what they need to output at the end
is
the schedule and this output the
schedule means they should output their
own part
of the solution in the schedule so they
should know in which of the ci's
are they contained and what we asked now
can we in this distributed model here
compute such setting schedules
efficiently
let me first say that we're not the
first people to study reconfiguration
this model has actually been done for
graph coloring we are given two
different
vertex colors colorings so here every
note initially knows their color that
they should have a green color at the
start and should have a red color at the
end for example
and you want to
always change keep changing vertices you
can change vertices in parallel
again you can only change independent
sets here in this model
and you should use as few additional
colors as possible so you have some
additional
colors to use here and in each
intermediate step you want to have a
feasible graph coloring
and it has also been studied for
independent sets
itself where you have initial
independence i need to go to some other
independent set
and here one cannot maintain the
property to always have a proper maximal
independent set
in the intermediate configurations but
we can only keep that one has an
independent set
but one has to loosen the condition
on maxima to actually compute schedules
to even have it solve these problems
but let's now go back to our problem
vertex curve reconfiguration in the
local model
now what i present now is our core tool
that we use to compute these which is a
small diameter small separator
decomposition
what you want
to do
because we've already seen that a node
in this model can only learn some
information from
close by and coordinate with vertices
that are close by
is that you want to group nearby
vertices together and then you actually
want to deal with these parts
at the same time to have a lot of
parallelism that they should be should
work in parallel without any
interference
and this is why
we
come up with such a decomposition which
decomposes the graph in small clusters
in clusters with small diameter because
in small diameter you can always compute
things efficiently in the local model
and the clusters are made independent
by inserting separators in between
separating nodes in between
these clusters
and the object that we obtain then is
what we call a small separator
decomposition and in fact it's a
decomposition of the graph into clusters
and the separator set such that each
cluster has a small diameter
and that separator set has few vertices
additionally and this basically
describes that the set is a separator
set each edge of the graph
is either completely contained in a
cluster like this what edge here
for example or has one of its endpoints
with this edge here in the separator set
so you cannot have an edge from one
cluster to another one so what we then
show
is that if you're given such a
decomposition
and you know that there exists
a good schedule for each
cluster this is the condition here on
the left hand side this is actually a
weak condition that it exists then we
can compute a
good batch schedule for the whole graph
to reconfigure from alpha to better for
the whole graph
and we just use a bit
the parameters in terms of the size of
the separator and the number of clusters
so let's try to prove this
result
so let's look at a first attempt on how
to solve it so let's actually look at
vertex cup and here you can already see
that the approximation will be violated
but here we're given some vertex cover
we have some vertices which are in beta
some which are in alpha and some which
are in both so the first attempt would
be to really separate these clusters
which means
this is our initial vertex cover alpha
and now we would add all
green
vertices
in the separating set to the vertex
cover so this would just be in the first
step we would add this vertex here so
now you can see really there are no
edges leaving a cluster that you need to
take care of really all these clusters
are independent we can just look at the
clusters independently
and we will never have a problem with
feasibility that we forget to monitor
any of the edges because all edges
leaving the clusters
will be covered at all times
so now we wish to just reconfigure both
of these clusters at the same time
but now what happens if you reconfigure
the left hand side cluster here well in
this cluster we have no chance otherwise
then we need to add the green vertex
here
what do we need to do in this cluster we
have no chance but to just add all of
the green vertices here so in the next
step what happens here is that actually
all the vertices here
are
in our intermediate vertex cover and in
the next step we finish the
reconfiguration inside the cluster so
we're still in step two here by removing
all these blue vertices here now we're
in a good situation again and now we
would remove all the blue vertices which
are not green from s in this
place there's none and what we've seen
now in the step two we at some point had
a lot of vertices inside
the cluster and this
violates the approximation guarantee
that we're given by our theorem so one
actually needs to do something a bit
smarter what one needs to do here
you
first reconfigure all clusters
in which
alpha has more nodes than better nodes
and only afterwards you reconfigure the
clusters in which better has more
nodes than alpha nodes so in this
particular example here we again first
add the separating node here
and now
would first reconfigure the left hand
side cluster
and not do anything at the writing side
cluster in this step
so
the schedule really would say here okay
first
we're done with this cluster now we've
already freed a lot of our capacity
and
only now the schedule
would
be
to reconfigure the right-hand side class
by adding the green vertices and then
removing the red vertices
so what i've been presenting here are
the schedules and not the actual
computation the actual computation here
in the local model is because of
is trivial because of the small diameter
of the
clusters so let me not go into the
detail computation of why we actually
achieved this approximation factor but
for those that are interested
i'll put
the calculations on the slides and you
can pause the video and look at them
instead let me now just emphasize that
this small separator decomposition comes
with three important parameters that
affect
our runtime on how
long does it take us to compute
the schedule but also the quality of the
schedule
so this x the size of the separating set
goes into the quality of the schedule
how good of an approximation is it the
number of clusters goes into
the quality of our approximation
and the diameter of the cluster goes
into the runtime
so basically the runtime of our local
algorithm will be if we take t rounds to
compute the decomposition
and our diameter is d then the whole
algorithm in the local model takes t
plus d rounds
so two of the parameters
are concerned with the quality
and
the diameter of the clusters with the
run time to compute the schedule
what can we obtain now
for computing such decompositions we can
basically get all these parameters small
we can compute these decompositions very
efficiently if the symmetric difference
of the vertex covers is a character's
graph and this is true for quite a large
class of graphs then in log star and
over epsilon rounds
we can compute
the d comma x separator decomposition
where x
is just an epsilon fraction of the
symmetric difference
the number of clusters is just epsilon
times the size of the vertex covers and
the diameter is also just one over
epsilon so all these parameters are
actually pretty good
and as a corollary by plugging in really
all the things that we've seen about
existential results
then the batch compression
computing such separator decompositions
then using them for computing
reconfiguring it's also that we can very
efficiently unlock star n over epsilon
rounds
compute in a distributed setting
schedules with order of one over epsilon
batches
which
are very close
to the best thing that you can
achieve they just have one plus epsilon
comma three
approximation guarantee
just say that the algorithm for this
cluster merging is inspired by ghs
and gkp
so these are distributed algorithms
for computing nsts
so basically what we do here is
we initially make every vertex their own
cluster
and then we keep merging clusters to
grow larger and larger clusters and
what is the main reason why we get a
small separator set because then these
clusters are not separated
well
what we use here is that cactus graphs
have
only
1.5 times the number of nodes edges and
they're actually also closed under
taking minors
so if you look at the cluster graph
where you take each cluster and contract
it to a single vertex then this cluster
graph will also have few edges and then
from each of these edges of the cluster
graph we will remove one of the vertices
so actually the separator set will be
roughly the number of clusters that we
get here
so we basically
grow the clusters until we have few
clusters then we create the
separator set
but
this is just a high level idea because
this might actually create new clusters
and a few additional tricks are needed
if you're interested in this
decomposition because it might actually
be
helpful for different problems as well
please have a look at the paper
so that's it thank you very much and for
open problems i didn't put anything on
the slide
let me just tell you all the things i've
been told to
hold for monotone schedules and that's a
big open problem and very unclear what
happens if the schedules are not
monotone anymore thank you very much